what I'd like to do in this video is
explore the core spiritual ideas of
Buddhism and we're going to do it
relative to the core spiritual ideas of
Hinduism is described in the Upanishads
one because there are significant
parallels and also because Buddha and
Buddhism grew out of a Hindu tradition
so in both belief systems there's this
notion that the reality that we are in
is a quasi illusion in the Upanishads
it's described as Maya that there is a
true self that there is this Atman which
is of the same substance as the true
nature of reality of Brahman that all
things are actually connected this
notion of the individual is just an
illusion a solution given to us by this
Maya and the Maya isn't just our sensory
perception it's even our notions of ego
and possibly even times base and
causality in Buddhism there's a parallel
notion that all of what we consider to
be reality is just happening in our mind
there isn't anything more real than that
and we are subject to this reality
because of our constant craving for that
which is impermanent this craving is
called Trishna which is the Sanskrit
word or Tana which is the Pali word the
language of Buddha now because of this
craving it leads to this constant
suffering this book which is really this
reality that we are subjecting ourselves
to now in either case we take action and
that action leads to consequences and so
in both traditions we have this notion
of Karma and that the Karma the actions
with consequences lead to further
actions and consequences not just in
this life but in future realities in
whatever next Maya or reality or life
that we take on and this constant cycle
of birth and rebirth is referred to as
samsara in both of the traditions so you
see this commonality
now in Hinduism there's this idea of
trying to escape from samsara through
meditation by being able to see through
the Maya and merge your Atman with
Brahman seeing that all are one in
Buddhism there's a similar idea through
meditation through following the
Eightfold Path by recognizing the Four
Noble Truths you should escape from this
craving of impermanent things and in
either tradition as you do that you
escaped from the samsara and when you
escape from the samsara and this cycle
of karma leading to more and more and
the Mayan God disappear in Hinduism the
term is moksha you have freed yourself
from this cycle in Buddhism the sanskrit
word is actually nirvana which literally
means bone out but it's merging with the
emptiness so even though officially a
Hindu might say through the moksha your
Atman is merging with the ultimate
reality of Brahman while in Buddhism
when you achieve Nirvana you have
recognized your non-self and it has
merged with the emptiness with the non
being now there is debate is Buddhism
saying that you should try to achieve a
state of non-existence many people would
disagree they would say Nirvana is
actually the ultimate bliss to recognize
your non-self some would say hey this is
just a matter of what words you use in
either case you are recognizing that
there isn't the individual that you are
merging with the true reality that
you're emerging with the universe
whether you consider the University
Brahman or whether you consider the
universe to be emptiness but in either
tradition this is viewed as a state of
release as a state of ultimate bliss and
something that you should try to get to
through practice